willkommen zurück bei uns instagram & co
mit social media plattformen da
verbindet man ja eigentlich eher schöne
und auch witzige bilder und clips doch
immer häufiger stellen genau die auch
eine gefahr dar kriminelle erstellen
fake-profile suchen über soziale
netzwerke ihre opfer locken sie in die
falle und dabei reichen die verbrechen
von betrug und stalking bis hin zu
gewalt und sogar mord ja leider keine
einzelfälle wie diese schlagzeilen ja
auch zeigen und auch bei dem fall den
wir ihnen jetzt vorstellen ist ein
16-jähriger der teenie falle instagram
zum opfer gefallen überlebt hat er nur
ganz knapp max k wird im sommer
vergangenen jahres opfer eines brutalen
mordversuchs im verdacht seine ex
freundin und ihr neuer freund von morgen
startet am landgericht bielefeld der
prozess wir haben jetzt schon alle
einzelheiten für sie einmal
zusammengefasst
es ist dieser ort an dem max nur knapp
mit seinem leben davonkommt hier in der
nähe von minden in nrw wird der 16
jährige in einen hinterhalt gelockt
opfer einer mörderischen liebesfalle
rückblick es ist der 31 juli vergangenen
jahres max verabredet sich mit jesse
kennt das mädchen nur von instagram zum
treffen begleitet ihn sein freund luca
ein relativ gutes gefühl halt einfach
hingefahren und soja wir lernen gleich
vielleicht ein paar nette mädels kennen
und dann mal gucken rostocks ergibt dass
er am ende des tages um sein leben
kämpfen muss ahnt max zu dem zeitpunkt
noch nicht am vereinbarten treffpunkt
wartete nicht seine internet-
bekanntschaft jesse auf ihn es ist ronja
seine ex gemeinsam mit ihrem neuen
freund kai k und als wir dort ankamen
die meinen kumpel auf die nase gehauen
dann haben die auf mich eingestochen
im selben moment
hat mein kumpel noch gesagt scheiße wir
müssen hier weg die haben den messer max
wird opfer eines heimtückischen
mordversuch st die polizei ist sicher
richtig zweimal aufs ein 16 jähriges
opfer ein
ein stich trifft den schüler in die
schulter der zweite seitlich in den
oberkörper nur knapp an der
hauptschlagader vorbei obwohl er
lebensgefährlich verletzt ist können max
und sein freund fliehen der 16-jährige
wird operiert er überlebt wenige tage
später nehmen ermittler ronja und kaka
feststellen beweismittel sicher doch bis
heute ist ihr motiv unklar im nachhinein
denke ich heute darüber das ist immer
noch nicht also ich kann es halt immer
noch nicht fassen dass das passiert ist
und dass das die das waren mit ihr habe
ich ja zusammen eine beziehung geführt
und das war dann schon also es ist
unfassbar und unvorstellbar morgen
startet der prozess wegen versuchten
mordes vor der jugendkammer des
landgerichts bielefeld sollten ronja und
kaka verurteilt werden drohen ihm bis zu
15 jahre haft
eine wirklich grausame tat die max nur
knapp überlebt hat und mit ihm wollen
wir jetzt darüber sprechen hallo max
jetzt zunächst natürlich erstmal die
frage wie geht es dir ja mir geht s
moment wieder zum glück wieder ganz gut
und ich bin froh dass ich hier sitzen
kann
was war das für ein gefühl damals oder
auch danach was ging ihnen der vor als
du realisiert hast was da passiert ist
ja das ist schon natürlich komisch dass
mir das persönlich passiert ist und ich
man kann es gar man kann es noch gar
nicht so wirklich realisieren dass es
einem selber passiert ist weil man was
da sonst nur so wirklich im fernsehen
mit krieg oder so
morgen startet der prozess bist du
aufgeregt hast du vielleicht auch ängste
ja natürlich dass man wenig aufgeregt
wenn es morgen die prozesse beginnen
aber ich gehe dann mit einem relativ
guten gefühl da rein weil ich weiß wenn
die prozesse jetzt dann zu ende kommen
und ist zu einem urteil kommt dass dann
die ganze sache vorbei ist und gehst du
heute anders um mit social media als
noch vor der tat ja natürlich ich bin
jetzt vorsichtiger als vorher und gucken
natürlich lieber drei viermal nachricht
wird immer irgendjemanden könnten
treffen würde
was wünscht du dir hooligans oracle
wünschst du dir für ein urteil morgen
oder in die nächsten tage wenn der
prozess gestartet
ja ich wünsche mir natürlich dass die
ihre gerechte strafe bekommen und lang
genug sitzen können nochmals zu
überlegen was sie überhaupt getan haben
und wenn wir das überhaupt angetan habe
was würdest du anderen raten mitschülern
von dir kollegen freunden was sollen sie
tun wenn sie auf instagram und anderen
social media unterwegs sind was hast du
daraus gelernt
ja passt auf was ihr macht im internet
und fragt lieber drei vier fünf mal nach
ob die person als wirklich echt ist
vielleicht noch bildern oder so
max k vielen dank dass du mit uns
gesprochen hast und ja das thema wie man
sich schützen kann wie man aufpassen
soll in der teenie falle instagram das
wollen wir jetzt auch mit einer cyber
experten besprechen und zwar mit
christine de hallo frau gaga
hallo was muss man beachten wenn man
social media mäßig unterwegs ist es gibt
mittlerweile so viel fake-profile wo
sich denn was ist echt was es vielleicht
nicht authentisch
es gibt ein paar gute merkmale für diese
profile oft sind die erst ganz neu
angelegt haben ähnlich posts und sehr
mit der regel mehr abonnenten als
follower das heißt derjenige versucht
andere zu abonnieren und hat weniger
verlor selber es gibt auch wenig likes
wenig stories die gepostet werden es
werden fotos verwendet die fast zu schön
um wahr zu sein sind also sprich so die
traumfigur bei der frau oder das über
trainierte man und das werden auch zu
kurznamen verwende der young band elisa
da da muss man immer ein bisschen
hingucken was hat das ja auch schon
gesagt kritisch nachfragen ist wirklich
wichtig und auch gucken ob jemand anders
aus dem freundeskreis mit dieser person
verbunden ist und auch dort nachfragen
ist zum beispiel ein guter tipp also das
ist das was man selber tun kann was
sagen sie sollen die sozialen medien
also die dienstleister tun
da habe ich zwei wünsche also das eine
ist natürlich wir haben auf instagram
über eine million menschen die sich dort
bewegen das ist technisch auch eine
herausforderung mit diesen identitäten
zu gehen ja und die im griff zu behalten
aber ich würde mir schon wünschen dass
die ein bisschen mehr prüfen wenn
accounts angelegt werden und dass sie
auch zum beispiel sind einstiegs
tutorial zur verfügung stellen wo die
nutzen denn darauf hingewiesen werden
auf solche
checks profile und wog nur die auch
melden kann weil der melde- prozess für
fake-accounts ist ziemlich gut versteckt
prince tagoe da muss man echt suchen
müssen wir das findet und oft ist es
auch in englisch also es gar nicht so
intuitiv und da würde ich mir wünschen
dass sie das transparenter machen so
dass es leichter ist wenn einem so was
auffällt auch das zu melden
wenn sie sagen dass es da auch mehr
druck von der politik geben muss in den
usa beispielsweise geschieht das ja
facebook chef mark zuckerberg dem ihr
auch instagram gehört musste da vor dem
kongress beispielsweise aussagen wir
haben andere dienste hier die im
zusammenhang beispielsweise mit den
crooner demonstration querdenker und so
weiter und so fort telegramm stichworte
gibt es dazu wenig druck auf seiten der
politik
also ich würde mir schon wünschen dass
wir klare den schutz der identitäten
einfordern weil das ist einfach das in
zentrale information zu einer person an
denen relativ viel dran hängt und wir
sehen halt dass der identitätsdiebstahl
immens zugenommen hat die letzten jahre
da werden daten gesammelt die dann
einfach auch für kriminelle zwecke
verwendet werden und das ist das ist
richtig gut gut also sozusagen das im
griff zu haben die identitäten die ich
auf meiner plattform habe dass ich dies
sicher
verwende und auch nachhaltiges es ist
technisch der herausforderung bei diesen
mengen aber es ist eigentlich pflicht
von unternehmen sich darum zu kümmern
und diese daten sauber zu schützen so
ist es vor dida und das absurde daran
ist auch wenn zum beispiel ein facebook
oder instagram account gesperrt wird
oder gehackt wird dann braucht es auch
diesen gang dass man sein ausweis
vorzeigt um zu identifiziert zu werden
es zeigen ich bin wirklich diese
personen die diesen account pflegt und
man könnte eigentlich eher sagen man
macht es vorab so hat man dann die
ganzen fake-profile aussortiert vielen
dank einschätzung und danke